[Music]  okay so we are on 24 points and uh  [Music]  the leader isn't 25  so i guess we stick to stick to the  strategy of playing  like whatever moves quickly  okay  okay okay so this is actually  not a blunder but there is no district  check here  it's like not a blunder but probably  blunder  i mean  knight xc4 knight xc4 was not blundered  because of queen a4 check  followed by a queen takes c4 but 93  check followed by 9g4 was probably  blundered  okay knight f4 so it's actually quite  sharp  i mean also we we need to decide if we  try to play the  [Music]  like well or we played  simple yeah i guess we play it simply  just take f2 take each one  looks quite bad for  [Music]  for white and we don't need to be  kind of insane  to win this confidently okay he resigns  this is actually very nice